la compagnie mais les fidèles et le
dirait d'or n'arrive pas trois mais tu
vas être maman vous fera sur moi non
fumeur c'est me voilà
que j'ai c'est mon préféré ce truc un
polochon grossesse à ses hyper
confortable c'est super confortable non
vettel c'est exactement ce que je
ressens
mais cette sensation un peu étrange mais
si on comptait déjà en raison d'avoir
déjà vécu le déjà vu exactement mais
c'est marrant parce que c'est pas
toujours finalement un salut à bonn bah
oui ben bien dormi mais super vrai parle
de coups bas en fait on parlait de
techniques modernes est tombé fallait de
la wally wood jr à tous
[Musique]
[Rires]
ma main
moi je présume que ça oui quoi pendant
sa grossesse n'est jamais l'impression
genre que papa y sentez un peu exclu
exclu m'expliquer de quoi je sais pas
moi c'est vraiment comme si on me disait
ben merci pour tes spermatozoïdes
maintenant tu sert plus à rien tu peux
mourir tranquille à vos questions ça se
passait très bien
excuse moi mais j'ai en fait j'ai un
déjeuner à l'eau oui
oui
nortel
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi je rentrais au cou donc c'est
mon tee shirts tranquille et regarde ce
qu'on a trouvé un bavoir nounours pour
l'union très peur le thème pas mon avion
son show non mais qu'est ce t'as mais
c'était un problème non non je te donne
ta première non jeu
[Musique]
à
oh
ça a bien oui d'ailleurs je suis désolé
la partie charte
je voulais juste qu'il ait la même
hauteur que toi et moi il me plaît bien
ne pas voir nounours
un temps bien la confiance des petites
docteur sur les foules demandez pas ce
que je voudrais changer la photo de ma
carte vitale
ça changerait pas du tout je vous trouve
au dessus et en fait comme ça une fois
je me suis fait voler mon portefeuille
j'avais changé mais c'est très compliqué
de changer ça
un petit écran vous n'avez pas internet
vous je compte en maintenant ses mains
[Musique]